so how do they if we get in the
situation right usually they would just
inflate their way out of it uh but if
you already have high inflation is the
game kind of
don't use our tools allow for some sort
of uh recessionary uh event to take
place or go ahead and accelerate the
inflation like is that the path is like
recession or inflation choose your
poison so even today
there's there's more stimulus coming and
and so you i think to to simplify this
that inflation inflation debate like
just to simplify it and
first principles
ask yourself
what would happen if government stopped
easing
what would you see what would you see if
the market was a free market
and what we would see is
is cash would explode in value but cash
for a while
u.s cash dollar
dollars would but after that after the
banking failures over and over and over
cascading around the world because it
would just keep on
the cat that counter party risk would
take down everything
the only cash that would
explode in value is the stuff under your
mattress
and and
prices would completely collapse but
into that vacuum
dictators would rise
into
because you wouldn't have food on the
streets you would you're on the shelves
you wouldn't uh you would there would be
no banking institutions there would be
no institutions left every institution
is built on top of this
global credit mess
and and it's a staggering size
of
imaginary money
and it has to
keep on blowing up
a bigger imaginary money to keep it
solvent
otherwise you initiate that credit
collapse so they have no choice
so
so they'll raise you'll get
raise interest rates and even the threat
of raising interest rates the the the
credit market is so they both both the
bond markets start to collapse and the
credit and they
and the equity markets start to collapse
and as that starts
to happen but they have to run fiscal
policies and they have to and as this
happens it doesn't just move into
central banking it moves into
consumers demand
more money to pay for higher prices and
it overtakes the and it overtakes the
political establishment
and politicians become the central bank
so the central banks get corrupted by
the state
there is no independence
and again just go back and ask yourself
what type of market would you see in a
free market and you'd see no market
because they're the manipulation is part
of the function globally
of money uh of money of central banking
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time